Benedict Mary's cooking lunch for her
family they've been living in this tiny
cabin for two years after the government
relocated them to this Warehouse they
share it with many others
the fishing community in Southern India
has traditionally lived by the sea But
Rising water levels wash their homes
away Mary blames a nearby pot project
for the devastation
all the coastal erosion started after
the construction of the port began the
land eaten by the sea was my ancestral
property look at that area of water
where those boats are kept a few years
ago that area was land our children
played football there we had evening
Leisure Time there now the sea has eaten
more than 150 meters of land
fishing communities in Kerala have been
protesting against the virinium port for
nearly five months they fear it will
destroy their livelihood and are
demanding the government's top
construction the project cost 900
million dollars the government says the
project meets environmental impact
requirements and will benefit the
economy once operational virinium will
cater for large ships competing with
similar ports in Dubai Singapore and
Colombo authorities say this is an ideal
location for the port which is expected
to create many jobs
some families support the project
sadanan sold his ancestral land to the
port developer he got more than eighty
thousand dollars and invested most of it
he says this will help the Next
Generation it is a good project I gave
land to authorities hoping it would come
to Kerala lots of people will get jobs I
am giving all my support to this project
the land was hard earned by my ancestors
so it should be completed most of the
port has already been built but
construction has stopped since protests
began the company has filed a court case
to complete what's left the government
says it wants to resolve the issue
peacefully we are trying to convince
them we are trying to provide them
whatever they ask except this demand
this thing so we have to take care of
them we are our people as a government
we have to look after them so we are
talking with them we are talking to
their leaders so also we have to ensure
that the low end order of the place is
ensured the community is anxiously
waiting for the Court verdict they
disagree with the government's
environmental assessment and want an
independent study they say they will
keep protesting till all their demands
are metall Al Jazeera virinyam Southern
India